the news first came from jerry dulac of
the pittsburgh post gazette that
steelers quarterback ben roethlisberger
and team president art rooney the second
had met
on tuesday and it went well
shereen williams and i spent a lot of
time last night trying to figure out
what
went well meant chris
but as of now the indications are
that that was the step the major step
the major piece toward working out
an arrangement to keep ben
roethlisberger with the steelers
for one more year and it may just be one
more year yeah
but it's at least one more year right
well i mean if you made me bet money i
would bet that it's one more year but
we'll see where it goes i mean
hey it's a big deal there's no doubt
about it big ben's a hall of fame
quarterback
you know won the super bowl two times
last year
hey there was enough good play of course
to justify
bringing him back i think what's scary a
little bit was the way they played right
at the end of the year
the way he looked a little bit and i do
think he was injured
you know i know enough people there in
pittsburgh that have led me to believe
he was banged up the knee issue was
real if you really study them on film
you know you could tell there was a
difference between
ben roethlisberger in week 15 and ben
roethlisberger in week seven
and i guess you know if you're a
pittsburgh steelers coach
owner or whatever you're hoping you get
that first half of the year big ben but
i do think that's a big if
and and we've talked about this many
times he plays the game very physical
he or he did play it very physical he's
a beat up guy
and you do at least i worry about him
wearing out as the season goes along and
you know big ben seems to think he's
okay and he's ready to come back and
play some more
you make a great point in that regard
though because it was confusing to say
the least reports were emerging on a
consistent basis
that there were issues with and concerns
regarding his
knees not just knee but knees but then
on the injury report
there was never any disclosure late in
the year that he had a
knee or knees issue which would mean he
was getting no treatment from the team
he wasn't missing practice
except for his habitual which is fine
not being critical a wednesday day off
day off the not injury-related day off
the veteran day off that so many players
around the league get
and the only way i could harmonize those
two short of the steelers just
flat out lying on the injury report oh
by the way in 2019 they were fined
by the nfl for lying on the injury
report because ben roethlisberger's
elbow
that finally gave out in week two
against the seahawks
had not been listed on the injury report
right and they knew there was a problem
but if they aren't lying again if they
learned their lesson in 2019 it tells me
that it may it's
just something he's dealing with right
an arthritic condition
possibly in one or both knees and that
doesn't get better i know that all sorts
of
of fancy things happen in the offseason
stem cell treatments guys going to
europe i don't know how much you can
get your knee to recover if you've got
arthritis in it
and i think it's a legitimate concern in
2021 and my
my look i i don't want to be be debbie
downer here but
i think both sides are going to regret
this by the time we get to november or
december
they're going to regret one more year
they're going to wish they hadn't done
it like brett favre in 2010
well that's what i keep coming back to i
i mean i i understand that thought i
mean that certainly crosses my mind too
i mean i don't think it's crazy i i
guess you know
the big question mike would be really
this to start it would just be
what like what other options have they
got right now you know they're stuck in
between a little bit
you know it's not like they're not gonna
make a play for deshaun watson
uh or maybe some of the other
quarterbacks that are gonna be out there
and you know have trade demands
i don't think they can afford to do that
at this point right now
you know they're a team that you know
we're seeing they're they're growing old
in front of us there's lots of holes
the offensive line has issues they
traded away
you know picks a few years ago to trade
up in the draft and get devin bush
so you know they have issues as a
complete
football team and i think you know more
or less they probably looked at it and
goes okay big ben
yep okay you think you're pretty good
you can play still
okay we we know we can win games with
big ben we do
we know and there's not a better option
out there for them at this moment so
it's almost like hey he's an nfl legend
he's your guy we're loyal we're the
pittsburgh steelers
and he's also serving as maybe a
band-aid you know for lack of a better
way to say it
for them to just buy some time here to
build their team and then you know of
course
get a plan together to get the next
quarterback of the future for the
pittsburgh steelers
well that's right because they can't go
20 years between franchise quarterbacks
like they did between terry bradshaw and
ben roethlisberger even though they made
it to one super bowl
somehow without a franchise quarterback
super bowl 30 it was a loss to the
dallas cowboys
with neil o'donnell throwing two balls
to a wide open larry brown the only
problem is larry brown was not a
steelers receiver at the time he was a
cowboys defensive back
other than than that one year you know
they were relevant
but they never could punch it through
because you didn't have
a great quarterback you need to have a
good enough quarterback
2005. well ben roethlisberger wasn't
great in the super bowl but he was good
enough to win
but he made some plays yeah right they
they need a franchise guy
right if they're gonna get to the top of
the mountain again
post ben they have to get to work on it
they can't just wait and coast and float
from one guy to the next
and hope their defense will be good
enough to carry them and maybe that
formula will work to a certain extent
but we saw it for 20 years it wasn't
good enough
to get them their fifth super bowl they
waited a long time for the proverbial
one for the thumb or the literal one for
the thumb
and they finally got it with big ben and
hopefully that was a a
lesson for them about moving forward
last week when kevin colbert spoke on
the matter the steelers gm
created the impression for me that they
weren't sure that it made sense
to continue with ben given
the changes that the salary cap will end
up
forcing upon the steelers sure i think
from roethlisberger's perspective
there were similar concerns even though
he was saying all the right things
publicly i think that behind the curtain
he's
he's saying is this really a super bowl
team do i really have a chance to go out
the way i want to go out
i don't know what's caused him to come
to the conclusion that he does i don't
think the extra 5 million in the salary
cap from 175 to 180 makes enough of a
difference and all of a sudden you wake
up and say
eureka this could be 2005 all over again
and i can walk off into the sunset like
jerome bettis did with a super bowl
trophy i i and and to me
i i i just if you don't think you got a
reasonable shot at winning at all
that one extra year is only going to be
a potential source of regret
eventually that's my concern and i i
still feel there's a certain law like
neither side wants to be the one who's
responsible
for ending this that that to me is a
factor in their decision to find a way
to keep it going for one more year well
don't you think like the dead cat money
and stuff like that
like you know i would think the the the
contract situation
you know the dead cat money whether it
retires or not anything like that is
going to be a factor here
i think and you add that to the matter
of wait we're not sure
we don't have the quarterback of the
future on our roster right now
i mean as i think we both agree we don't
think mason rudolph's that guy
dwayne haskins maybe but it's not ready
right now
i mean that they they took that they
signed dwayne haskins going
hey we saw this kid he's got talent you
know he might be a
a you know a you know what do they say a
diamond in the haystack or what what the
heck no that's the needle of the
haystack what are they doing on the
haystack diamond in the rough diamond in
the rough right so you know you create
line in the sand
right they they're all good you know man
it's good to be back at work but yes
uh i think they're taking a shot they're
just hoping that they can strike gold
with with dwayne haskins and let him
develop a year and maybe learn behind
duane has
ben roethlisberger and you have
something there so
i would think mike i mean just that base
value it would be those two things
together right that would lead them to
all right hey it didn't end the way we
wanted it didn't look
great at the end of the year but there
still is a lot of good
players on this team and maybe they
don't want to go through the growing
pains of having to get a new quarterback
or do that maybe they do believe that
they can fill
in the the voids and and fix this team
enough to where
they feel like they can go back to the
afc playoffs and be one of the top seeds
and still be really relevant in the
afc playoffs and maybe make a run of
this now what was odd yesterday
was the impression created by the
initial report from jerry dulac that
they had the meeting and it went well
because it
it didn't finish the thought how did it
go well
are we going to have a retirement press
conference you know what what does it
mean for it to go well
from ben's perspective from the team's
perspective it's possible there are
different definitions based upon where
you're coming from as to what it means
to go well there was a statement
issued by ben roethlisberger's agent
ryan toner to adida king cabwala of nfl
media and
and here it is they want ben back and
will contact me
soon to address his cap situation as
we've shared since the season ended we
are happy
to creatively adjust his contract to
help them build the best team possible a
year ago
ben wasn't sure if he could throw again
he battled back to get 12 wins and the
eighth division title of his career
they lost steam down the stretch and
that doesn't sit well for him
so the fire burns strong and there is
plenty of gas
in the tank now the cap number
is the critical question here and the
the article we posed last night
indicated and suggested and analyzed the
question of whether or not the steelers
can
or whether they even want to pay him the
19 million he's due
to make this year cap number 41.25
million
if he retires or if he's cut it's 22.25
million
those are from the sins of salary caps
passed that they've kicked
money forward into this year the
question is what do you do with 19
are they going to try to get them to
take less are they just going to take
that 19
drop it down to the minimum salary of
1.075 million take the rest of it and
turn it into a signing bonus that gets
it spread over multiple years you can
get the salary cap number
in the range of 25 or 26 that way you
still have to take the excess later
but my my understanding and current
belief is
it's not about reducing the 19. now
maybe they'll drop that bomb on the
steel on the on
on roethlisberger's camp today but it's
never been about reducing the 19
and if that's the case chris point i
made last night this should take five
minutes
it's not hard to take that contract and
reduce the cap number this year
by moving money around by by moving
dollars around
if you're not taking money away from ben
roethlisberger it should not be
difficult to do no it should not and i
mean
from everything we know big ben's
totally up for it right i mean he's got
no problem doesn't cost him a penny
right so it doesn't make it it doesn't
make any difference to him
he'll do what he needs to do to help out
the team of course he's at a point in
his career
like a lot of these guys he's made a ton
of money and it's really more now about
he wants one more chance to play for the
big one
that's what it's all about and the big
question that i think you have to think
of is just
can he get you to that point and the
steelers i still think are a team you
know mike tomlin i would imagine he's
going no i i think we can still go to
the super bowl in 2021.
i'm sure a lot of those guys in that
team do with that defense
know devin bush this past year bud
dupree got hurt and i know he's a free
agent and we'll see what happens with
all that
but big ben this is where to me it's a
little different
you know because i've had so like some
people text me like well what's the
difference between big ben and the drew
brees situation
you know hey both legends hall of famers
awesome i mean you know
just respect all around but there is a
difference to me on the play on the
field too
big ben can still make defenses defend
the whole field
he can do that his arm is still good
enough as we saw even though it's not as
explosive as it once was
we still saw plenty of deep passes to
deontay johnson and chase claypool
all year long to go okay he can stretch
the field
the biggest thing in pittsburgh that
they need to do
and i don't know whether the blame is on
big ben here
you know the old offensive coordinator
uh or just the organization in general
they just can't play the freaking same
way they played last year
they can't do that that was unrealistic
it was almost
unfair to big ben and i do think he
probably had a hand in that i mean he
admitted that there was rpos that he
kept throwing the ball
and doing that but it goes back to like
what you talked about yesterday with
jerome bettis they never
really gave an attitude or commitment to
the run game early in the year
and then they got into whoa we're gonna
rely on our really
an older quarterback to sit in the
shotgun and make throws all game
so that has to change if they want this
to work at least in my opinion
and i think that's probably the next
remedy they got to think about o-line's
got to improve
you know and we got to get a running
game if you want to make it happen with
big ben
a la tom brady in the bucks protect them
up
let them feel good and if there's
one-on-one i promise you
big ben's gonna throw strikes to chase
claypool and deontay johnson all day
long and i think that's a part of this
equation as well
yeah even if juju smith schuster leaves
they've still got plenty of
resources right that ben can target and
i think part of it too
is and who knows how much we'll ever
find out about the discussion between
roethlisberger and rooney but but ben
does need to meet them
halfway because we heard from enough
different people
that that ben was taking liberties with
the play call
right ben was calling was changing runs
to passes or the rpos
choosing to throw when maybe the right
move would have been to hand off and
part of it is randy fickner who isn't
back as offensive coordinator they
brought in matt cannon the last year as
the quarterbacks coach
he's now the offensive coordinator and
one of the things he was bringing to the
table
the jet motion the the efforts to
confuse a defense
with all the movement behind the line of
scrimmage maybe you hand it off to chase
clay pool maybe you don't they got away
from that
right as the year went on and it was
just dink and dunk short passes and
and one of the reasons for the drops
that you identified was the fact that
the defensive backs all knew that it was
going to be a quick pass
so you t up and you go hit the guy and
and knock the ball
loose and and the guy starts hearing and
seeing footsteps
because he knows he's going to get
blasted because the defense is expecting
that
short pass uh and and uh that that was
not sustainable
and we saw it in the disintegration of
the team yeah that's exactly right i
mean it just it's too
you know what was the phrase they became
you know predictable within their
predictability i mean that's really what
it was it was like hey we know you're
going to throw it every play
and now we know you're going to throw
the play every every play is going to be
six yards right here and you're going to
have to jam it in there and really make
high-risk throws with not so great of a
reward
on top of that and as the season went
along we
saw it's just everybody knew what to
expect there was not enough diversity
within the offense
there wasn't enough even even if you're
gonna throw the ball every play there
wasn't enough schemes and things to go
around to where i was going
okay wait they might be able to survive
this they're doing a lot of cool stuff
in these formations wow okay they might
be able to throw it every play no
you know i would sit there and go i've
seen this route combination
six times already and we're in the third
quarter i've seen this route i've seen
this play five times and we're only
through a quarter and a half of the
football game
and within that that that's just that's
not fair either so
you know they got to find a way that's
going to work for their offense and
certainly change it just does not make
sense
with that defense uh and the way they
play that they were playing that style
of offense this year it put too much
pressure on the defense in too many
games too and it wasn't fair to them
either
i think the other reality at play here
too yeah we're now six weeks removed
from when the steelers
lost to the browns in humiliating
fashion at home
yeah in the wild card round of the
playoffs and and i think that
what happens is when you get into off
season mode
and everyone is zero and zero that's
when you go back to the lab
and you start coming up with reasons why
next year will be different and as you
get time
and distance from the way it ended
and and the way the the regular season
fell apart down the stretch
you start coming up with reasons why
next year we won't step
into that same trap next year we'll get
off to a good start
and we'll finish it becomes an echo
chamber oh we got this idea we got that
idea
and and you built and it's happening
throughout the league in
some cities probably never does but it
it it's it's happening everywhere
as you are isolated from the other teams
and you start thinking of all the the
great ideas as to how to move forward
you let yourself think you know what we
can do it yeah what who says we can't
why not us
and the next thing you know you start
making decisions based upon that
confidence that starts to pop up in
february
as you as you get farther away
sure from from how it all went sideways
on you the prior season and i think that
allowed both sides
steelers and ben roethlisberger to come
to the conclusion that
yeah let's do this again even though i i
really do think and i'm i just think
if i was a steelers fan if i put myself
in those shoes
if i started waving a terrible towel
right now i'd say man there's a chance
that this is a huge mistake
it's risky we know that i mean he he is
he's a risky no biscuit yeah well he's
he's a car crash quarterback it's rare
to say that i mean but he he really was
he was a car crash quarterback
you know that's where i feel bad for
guys like big ben and sometimes because
they had to play the game
on the edge all the time for a number of
years
and people aren't going to maybe
understand their greatness and how
good he was or other players like that
because they were in you know
compromised situations a lot
but yet the team was like hey you're
awesome we don't care you'll figure it
out you'll make a play
you'll you'll dance around the pocket
and run like fred flintstone like he
used to and move around and people on
them and throw the ball i mean big ben
was amazing like that he really was
the guy that could scramble within the
pocket and yet keep his eyes downfield
as good as i've ever seen really um
you you said a lot of good things there
too yeah i mean you're right nfl teams
are going to go back they're going to
reevaluate themselves
they're going to look at things i think
they're going to go man this happened
this happened if that didn't happen
you're right we can justify oh maybe we
would have been in a better spot
all of those type of things but i think
ultimately
the other thing that that they have to
come back to there's two things
they had to have looked back at the year
and just gone man
that was crazy that we were asking big
ben to play this way
it just they had to at least i've
realized that
we were the last team in football and
running the running the ball
and we have one of the more older beat
up quarterbacks in the nfl
that makes no sense when that comes out
of your mouth it doesn't even sound
right
and then i think the other thing that
maybe maybe just because i think about
this but
maybe gives them that little confidence
to go wait we can do this
is maybe they see the bucks in the super
bowl and they go
wait like if we gotta we can protect the
guy a little bit
and run the ball big ben could throw the
post down the middle and the in cut and
the deep outs and do
all that too so i think again with all
the things we've said
lack of options their salary cap
all of that i i think that's probably
where we have we've been you know
we're led to this point and uh we'll see
where it goes but i do think big ben can
still make plays with that right arm
one of the one of the basic realities
that i've witnessed over the years being
in and around pittsburgh
when when you write them off that's when
they are the most dangerous
and it's easy to write them off going
into this year given the changes that
salary cap situation
likely will cause and maybe they'll find
a way to wave the magic financial wand
and work it all out but whatever the end
result
it's going to be easy to look at the
steelers and say uh they're not ready to
compete with the ravens they're not
ready to compete with the chiefs they're
not ready to compete with the bills
they're not ready to compete with the
browns
that may be the that may be the thing
that starts the lawnmower for the
steelers like nothing
ever did before getting beat by the
browns
again it may be unjustified confidence
but that confidence is there and that's
excellent point you watch the super bowl
and you know this is a team that mike
tomlin was working for the last time
they won the super bowl in 2002
it's easy to say there are things we can
take
from what the buccaneers did all year
long incorporate it into our game
and our aging quarterback can maybe get
his
his hands on a lombardi trophy and walk
off into the sunset like jerome bettis
did that's clearly the goal that's the
motivation
that's why they're doing it this isn't
about a paycheck
for ben roethlisberger and this isn't
about a farewell tour
for the steelers in big ben and uh where
do they you know
the thing is that they're gonna have to
trim some fat on their roster i mean
there's certainly some guys you look at
you okay you take care of that situation
right there and you go all right that's
gonna give them some money maybe they
can get out in free agency and get
you know a new center or you know
another guard
maybe a tackle something like that to
help them out of course the draft is
gonna that they're in no man's land for
the quarterback in my opinion with the
draft
i don't think that's gonna happen and
you know you look at other guys like
you know joe hayden all right because i
you know of course i knew we were gonna
talk about this you look at their roster
their salary cap situation
hey he's a guy that's cap hit 15 and
15.5 million dollars but if they
they cut them it's only 2.9 million
dollars they can trim a lot of money
right there that's two or three players
on your roster i mean that's really so
they're gonna have to work some magic
and do some you know rebuilding and
things like that and make some tough
decisions no doubt about it but
i'm not gonna count the steelers out yet
not because of like what you said
there's just too many awesome
crazy alphas on that football team right
now for me to count them out there
really is i mean
one the coaches that way two it's one
beast after another on the defensive
side of the ball
and you know the receivers you know
decent tackle play i mean they're
they're not
too too far off and then you get a guy
like devin bushback
who was really a huge blow to them last
year at middle linebacker
you know we we we certainly could be
sitting here next december going
hey here's pittsburgh they're they're
going to go to the playoffs or got a
chance to go to the playoffs i wouldn't
be surprised by that
you know what they desperately need they
desperately need a frank o'haras they
need a guy they draft who comes in
right away and makes a huge impact in
the running game because
they don't have that and i don't know
that the revolving door james connor
benny snell
whoever else they put out there anthony
mcfarlane i i don't think that's going
to be the answer they need a workhorse
who can't hey it's easy to commit to the
running game
when you get a guy who comes in and
everyone is saying
damn right holy crap hold give him the
ball again
that's the way to balance the offense
the way it needs to be balanced
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports